beeping welcome to Washington on my
command you infer bret baier breaking
tonight Christmas is over and Hanukkah
ends this evening members of both the
Christian and Jewish faiths were under
attack over the weekend we have Fox team
coverage correspondent Jeff Paul's in
Texas where a gunman opened fire in a
church killing two but for a parishioner
with a gun it could have been much worse
correspondent Jillian Turner looks at
the rise of anti-semitism religious hate
and what President Trump is doing about
it but we begin with correspondent
Jackie Heinrich in New York where the
accused in the latest attack against
Jewish people now faces federal hate
crimes bdb Jackie
good evening Mike the suspect in this
case now faces federal hate crime
charges as private armed security guards
stand outside the synagogue tonight
after the county called in extra help
except behind State Police and
detectives they'll be going to these
different two in a very very menacing
omnipresent truck Jewish people in
Muncie New York feel that's necessary
after a rampage at a rabbis home on the
seventh night of Hanukkah police say 38
year old Grafton Thomas bursted in with
a machete and said no one is leaving
stabbing five people including the
rabbi's son before trying to get into
the synagogue next-door worshippers
chased the man out throwing tables and
chairs and got his license plate
NYPD tracked him down in Manhattan and
investigators allegedly found disturbing
evidence in his car a journal with
anti-semitic statements and references
to Nazis and Adolf Hitler they also say
Thomas researched other Jewish temples
online scores of papers which frankly
show the ramblings of a disturbed
individual New York Governor Andrew
Cuomo labeled it an act of domestic
terrorism and vowed to crack down on an
alarming recent uptick in anti-semitic
attacks since December 23rd there's been
one anti-semitic attack each day on
Christmas Day a man in traditional
clothing was punched in the face in
Brooklyn the day after someone beat a
Jewish mother over the head with a bag a
suspect in a third case is already back
on the street under New York's new bail
reform laws she's not enough of a threat
to be held before trial
she's accused of punching and yelling
slurs at three Orthodox women President
Trump called for unity against
anti-semitism but the Munsey suspects
family says this is not what it seems
claiming Thomas isn't part of any hate
groups but after serving in the Marines
he developed bipolar disorder and
schizophrenia being hospitalized many
times and because of his age his mother
could only do so much to get him help
he's always been a gentle giant with
mental illness investigators have not
commented on reports that this suspect
is also being investigated in connection
to another stabbing at a synagogue in
this very same town last month mike
jackie how did the federal hate crime
charges impact the potential sentence so
Mikey can be prosecuted at the state
level for the attempted murder charges
and they carry their own set of
penalties at the same time he can be
prosecuted at the federal level for the
hate crime charges and depending on the
theory of prosecution they pursue there
could be different penalties and the
documents show that the feds have left
their options open they could either
pursue bodily injury which carries a
penalty of up to 20 years or they could
go for the attempt to kill that means
that he could be put away for life or if
one of the victims dies of their
injuries he could face the death penalty
Mike
Jackie Heinrich thanks very much